johnny tu raconte l'anecdote avec
l'hélico stade de france qui vole c'est
l'hymne a dit qu il ya pas si longtemps
que c'était son meilleur souvenir
d'entrer en scène que jenny nature eu d
entrée fracassante mais là j'avais
travaillé des mois et des mois parce que
il voulait absolument faire une entrée
en hélicoptère j'ai dit moi n'a pas dit
c'est pas possible j'ai dit à la parade
survolée une foule
sauf si c'est le samu il m'a dit ben tu
viens avec 5 hélico du samu on n'a pas
lâché
il m'appelait la nuit et il m'appelait
six mois avant il ne savait pas en 98
qu'il ferait son premier ca de france
juste après la victoire de deschamps et
de zidane
donc c'était la cerise sur le gâteau il
m'appelait la nuit parce que johnny
appelé la nuit soit parce qu il rentrait
tard soit parce qu'il a oublié décalage
horaire et lapointe afin qu'ils
m'appellent c'était en janvier 98 il me
dit est ce que comme ça
sur les 90 minutes 1 89m je dors à la
mbc johnny tu dors pas je suis à ton
avis oui est ce que tu as vu apocalypse
now parce que papa grippe nord robert
duvall
il attaque le vietnam avait catelli côte
va faire la même chose bonne nuit je me
réveille ma famille dit qu'est ce que tu
as jeudi pout j'ai fait un rêve
j'attaquais le stade de france devant 85
mille spectateurs avec johnny je
pilotais l'hélicoptère de l'escadrille
et je déposais johnny sur la foule mais
ma femme m'a dit tu as fait un cauchemar
c'est devenu un cauchemar quelques jours
plus tard 81 matin c'est johnny y sont
prêts les hélicos studio il m'a eu à
être tenus cet hélico et il a fait une
entrée hallucinant bio